so are we live yeah
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this meeting of the stratfor naval
district council cabinet
i'm tony perks i'm the deputy chief
executive of the district council
unfortunately our leader councillor tony
jefferson is unwell today and the deputy
leader counts the pemberton to design
his holidays
um so my first duty today is to ask for
nominations for a chair for this meeting
nominations councillor parry
i'd like to uh nominate councillor
trevor harvey and i'd like to second
that thank you
any other nominations
all right um go to show of hands
excellent councillor harvey your
chairman for the day
thanks to that vote of confidence um can
i start the meeting by referring to
robert weeks
robert has done 36 years service with
this council and is retiring at the end
of the month
um i'd like to
i'm sure there are going to be other
occasions when people are going to say
lots of lots of nice things about robert
um and i would just for the sake of our
minutes i'd like to be able to record a
formal proposal for voter thanks for
these years of service do i have a
proposal
and a second it thank you very much
i'd be grateful if that would be
recorded in the minutes
second matter i'd like to draw to your
attention
is
excuse me
items 9 and 10 on the agenda
are there for discussion if somebody
wishes to request a discussion at this
stage in the meeting in the absence
of a request i shall deal with those
appropriately
moving on then to item one on the agenda
apologies for absence we clearly have
apologies from tony jefferson leader and
darren pemberton deputy leader are there
any of that yes we do we also have
apologies from councillor o'donnell and
anything from the your view and scrutiny
meeting councillor juned will be feeding
back on her behalf thank you
mr perks uh mr buckland our chief
executive asked me just to pass on his
apologies for not being with you in the
room he's suffering from a bit of a cold
so he's with us digitally but didn't
want to spread his germs who just has to
record that that's most kind of
um
moving on in item two disclosures of
interest are there any
uh items of disclosure that people want
to make
i see none we move on item three
uh minutes of our last meeting
on the sixth of september i don't
propose to go through them page by page
um is there anybody who wishes to raise
any question of inaccuracy in those
minutes
no
fine
i raised one point
in my usual style
i do wish that in future we can avoid
split infinitives
uh there are at least four issue four
occasions
when uh the phrase is used to not
endorse
when it what we really mean is plain
english not to endorse so i'd be
grateful if it be noted that some of us
don't like split infinitives
moving on
part a that part a deals with matters to
be referred to the council and we have
one item
dealing with service integration and
accommodation and i gather councillor
cargill is going to introduce this item
thank you chair
the paper before you detailed the next
and most important steps in the merger
between warwick and stratfor district
councils
the first recommendation asks that to
achieve the projected savings we need to
progress the service integration along
with the time scales contained in the
report
the time scales are ambitious but
necessary to achieve the deadline of a
single unified workforce by may
2024 the second recommendation is just
as important in that it will guide the
form of the new accommodation for the
merged council
given the major changes in working
practices over the last year or so
the form of the new accommodation will
take some time to arrive at and could
well be a hybrid solution
it is therefore important important that
we start the process now
chair the recommendation to councils
contained on page 11's report
that
irrespective of the decision relating to
the full political merger of
stratford-on-naval district council and
warwick district council expected in
december 2021 work progresses on the
full service integration of teams across
stratford and warwick district councils
and two
work progresses on the identification of
shared civic and office accommodation
between stratford on avon district
council and warwick district council
a recommendation to cabinet is subject
to recommendation
to council being approved that the
timetable timetable for service
integration as set out in the report
dependence one table one be agreed thank
you chair
thank you councillor goggle i wonder if
we could deal with the recommendation to
counsel first
are the members of cabinet who would
like to speak on that recommendation
counselor kettle
i'll start again
sorry and i said i wasn't going to speak
on page 17
there was the table reproduce reproduced
from the um
uh deloitte's report
uh suggesting by 2526 uh that we're
saving between both council
3.76 million
um
are we still comfortable
that these savings are realistic and um
after all the additional work's been
done
uh possibly as portfolio holder or the
money side mr chairman
uh is there an upside on that well we
might see more savings
thank you council kettle i'm in the
chair for the day uh
mr beg your pardon councillor cargill
would you like to respond to cancer
kettle
i am not aware of any changes that have
come forward to me at this stage um it's
dynamic
and it depends on things like for
example the speed of the integration how
how quickly we can merge the two
organizations and also the the amount of
stuff that's involved in this process
next i suppose will be things like for
example accommodation so i i cannot
answer that i'm afraid unless
mr buckland has anything he would like
to add to that
mr buckland would you like to comment
generally um i think i think my comment
will be that the figure the combined
figure 3.8 million pound is is slightly
below that deloitte should forecast
within the report so i think it is a
a prudent estimate of what could be
delivered um and there is
a total of both the savings that could
be derived from this the service
integration and the accommodation side
so
i would like to say that yeah i believe
at this point that those levels of
savings are achievable by the council
thank you mr buckland there any other
member of cabinet who'd like to speak
councillor shenton
thank you chair and just following on
from uh councillor kettle
i'm just wondering
would there be any difference in the
projected savings if we
chose
if you like the lead council model over
the section 113 model um is that going
to have any material effect at all
council cargill
chairman if i could respond no the the
level of savings would be expected to be
the same whichever model is pursued
anybody council parry
thank you chairman um it's really just
as much as an observation
i'm certainly in support that work
progresses at the
fastest pace
i am aware that there are a number of
differences on the it systems between
the various departments which is really
the the biggest challenge and therefore
it is absolutely critical that work
starts sooner rather than later
certainly as the portfolio holder for
planning
they operate
onto different
planning i.t
property management type of systems so
the sooner work commences the better but
i t for me is is the key issue in this
whole process thank you council parry i
think we'd all agree that the bedrock of
the integration of the service of the
two depend fundamentally depends upon
the it working
thank you um can i just ask for
clarification
that on page 21 we're talking about
three tranches of implementation
and then cancer markers page 21 refers
to the next paper
party work refers to the appendix
yeah um
we've got the trenches and then on page
27 we have the
phases are these phases within the
tranches
am i making you smile mr butler yes it's
that it's my kind of question can you
just
little brain tell me thank you
another policies for the confusion
through you chair the the process has
developed somewhat at first we were
looking at three chances we have
we named them phases if you like so
apologies for the confusion that have
actually merged um chance one and two to
become phase one that said there is a
part one to phase one that includes the
proposed um service integration of ict
legal services and environmental
services and then the remainder of phase
two the sorry phase one is set out in
the paper so apologies for the change in
terminology there
may i just comment that this is what
happens when you leave accountants in
charge
thank you for choosing remark i hope the
question of tranches doesn't become a
question of trenches eventually
cancer tuna did you want to say a word
i'm just um
want to say something that the chair of
the ovu and scrutiny committee pen
counselor pena o'donnell noted um she
noted that um
again on the finances uh and was
concerned about the finances and noted
the reliance of this council on the new
homes bonus and asked how will uh there
be a change and more will there be a
more outward looking and income
generating uh focus uh to the district
council or will there need to be um as
we move forward
uh mr buckland would you like to deal
with that rather than myself as the
portfolio
holder thank you chairman i think
the medium-term financial plan that was
approved in in february this year
identified how the council is moving
away from its reliance upon new homes
bonus and i think from memory and i
haven't got the figures ahead of me at
the moment we we are estimating
in excess of five million pounds of new
homes bonus in the current year reducing
to one million pounds next year and then
the sum of new homes bonus whatever that
that may be have a much lower figure
contained than the mtfp i i think the
points well made about trying to find
alternative sources of financing to
support the council's budget
i i will say that the garden waste
challenging service was one of those
such proposals and pleased to report
that that has over recovered in relation
to the amount of income that's receiving
so
yes as the the peer review challenge
identified i think it's two or three
years ago now that the council
given
its reliance upon central government
support needs to find alternative ways
to finance its activities
thank you mr buckland uh i do think
councillor o'donnell has a point it's an
obvious point that structurally the
council has become dependent upon new
homes bonus which he was entitled to do
for revenue purposes uh and there is a
a need to
uh diversify the sources of income
that the council can generate and steps
clearly have been taken over the past
year or two to that end
and councilor o'donnell was reflecting
uh the the the concerns of the whole
ovule and scrutiny committee but that
was her final wording right thank you
very much uh on that basis have we
concluded
that we haven't i'll take a pardon
thank you chair just a brief comment
that um
from a climate change point of view
i'm pleased to see
the comment of 4.5.1 on page 13 and
obviously for obvious reasons
i would support this uh the
recommendations and
as cancer period said would look to see
this move ahead quite quickly
uh noted mr chancellor shenzhen
cancer kettle
um
[Music]
thank you just a minor point of
clarification
um clearly um
there's a table in appendix
too
um there's a question for mr grafton
could you give the page number please
page 24 24 thank you um
district council have a an awful lot of
casuals listed
and one thing that slightly um
surprised me i wondered if um well
clearly our last march to do it but if
mr grafton might be able to help him uh
law and governance
we have 56 people in the legal
department at work district council
including 41 casuals
um now i can understand with tourism
where you have people in the summer
uh helping in tourism and and this that
the other but i mean the legal
profession and the um government side is
what you might call fairly static
thank you how can you get
casual you've made your point
mr grafton would you like to comment on
that
um i would um
having only been
a head of law and governance for about
six weeks i'm i'm having to catch up
with
arrangements over at warwick so what i'm
about to say is speculative to some
extent
um certainly i would say that
warwick does not have 56
head count as i understand it
um i just wonder whether some of it
might be casual stuff that they bring in
for elections because
similarly to the democratic services
team here um that they're responsible
for that that's that part of the service
is responsible for the elections too
and some of those staff might very well
be
casual staff that are taken on for
an election but i will i will check that
out for you and come back to the to the
cabinet on that
thank you mr grafton
thanks thank you chairman yeah i think
in in addition to the actual elections
itself i i would suggest that that the
casuals here could indeed relate to the
register of the acts uh the actual
maintenance of the register of electors
and the annual canvas which is
undertaken by by councils we we also
employ casual staff to help us with our
canvas and i would like to uh trail that
we're gonna start that canvas exercise
very soon so so please return your
registered lecture forms if you haven't
already done so but but i i imagine that
part of it would also relate to that
particular activity but we can get
clarifications for the sake of the mix
thank you very much
um that is a matter of detail and as we
all know there are people who turn up as
casuals intending to say a week that
some
stay a month some stay a lifetime
since then
are we
are able to deal with the recommendation
to council
all those in favor would they please
show
all those against
abstentions not six nil
seven they'll take apartments
thank you recommendation to cabinet is
there anything further you'd like to say
cancer cargill
only this is
as i mentioned a very important step and
really and truthfully uh we're on on a
journey now it's a one-way trip
thank you
thank you very much i think we can move
to the
the motion being proposed and
seconded
proposed
proposed
missed casa cargill seconded council
jennings all those in favor
all those against
carried thank you
item five on the agenda
um
this is a
in itself is a substantial paper
and it relates to even more substantial
papers available in the appendices
uh i think uh mr carefort is going to
do the honours introduce this item
come in mr careful
thank you uh mr chairman afternoon
members
um
yes as uh kelsov has said um
you've got some quite detailed uh
technical reports here uh there's a
number of components uh to lumicott's uh
flood risk which covers fluvial and
surface water you've got heritage which
covers um
assessments on the reserve housing sites
or proposed reserve housing sites as
well as some site specific proposals and
you've got higher wage assessments
looking at
biddeford on avon stratford upon ivan
and sell them
um
i i won't try and summarize uh the those
reports uh now because i can't really do
them justice
there's been a lot of work undertaken um
behind the scenes and to get them
to you members um i do have colleagues
uh paul harris and matthew neal
who are with us virtually
if you did have slight more detailed
questions of the the lead officers on on
these pieces of work um but
if with your forbearance members if
there are
particularly detailed questions we may
need to uh come back to you slightly um
after the meeting offline as it were
just to give you a
definitive answer on any uh particular
technical matters um but perhaps if i
can just provide some context if that
would be helpful
so we do need robust uh pieces of
technical work to inform plan making
namely in this case the site allocations
plan
um and there are a number of
recommendations in here that we need to
take on board as we prepare the uh the
site locations plan and
take into account in terms of its next
iteration in due course
but perhaps the
the biggest issue that these reports
sort of highlight and bring to the fore
is the
the level of infrastructure constraint
that the district is is facing
um
and i i think really moving forwards you
know under the the southwesterly local
plan we really need to think carefully
about uh how we do plan for and how we
fund
infrastructure moving forwards and that
applies not just the district uh you
know
to the the country as a whole really so
i i think these are some there's some
challenging issues here that these sort
of studies are starting to throw up but
so they
uh we've gone through them they've been
prepared by expert consultants we're
happy with what they're saying and we
will use them as i say to inform um
plan making as per the recommendation so
hopefully they they can be uh can be
received as technical evidence um i will
just point out uh members there is a
typo on paragraph 1.4.8
and it should be uh it should be illicit
not illicit
um
slightly unfortunate typo but if we can
just correct that on the report
uh but if there are any questions uh
happy to take them thank you members
thank you mr kevin questions for members
of cabinet
cancer cargill thank you thank you john
um on item one two ten on page thirty
one we talk about um climate change flu
fuel uh flooding uh climate hundred year
um
yeah plus uh climate change etc
now obviously this applies to all of the
items or the the sites that have been
like allocated here and
does that apply to all residential sites
including for example gypsy travelers
sites
question for sean mr carefoot
i'm wondering if my colleague mr harris
might know the answer to that one um
obviously the the principles uh do it do
apply it's um yeah it's how you apply
them to the different development types
i wonder if paul is able to shed in
light on that one
i think each other well certainly that
is the case uh the level
on and now level two strategic flood
risk assessments that consultants have
produced for the district council
have specifically looked at
that these sites that have been coming
forward to the site allocations plan
but that the principles would apply to
any development proposal
and i think it's important to
understand that
most planning applications will need to
be
accompanied by a more detailed flood
risk assessment that comes in with the
application
so
that the work that we've commissioned
from consultants is quite high level
it's necessary in order to identify
sites which fundamentally should not be
developed
and to identify those sites where
perhaps parts of
the area that like the gross area
shouldn't be developed in order to
identify the net
developable area so the the the scope of
these studies specifically to do with
informing the council as we produce the
site allocations plan but the principles
set out in the study would apply to many
sites
thank you thank you for the clarity of
your explanation
for the questions from members of
cabinet
cancer barca
yeah i think again um this may be a
question for john and his team
but
one of the things that i notice is that
um we do we do these flood risk
assessments for
our planning purposes
and it would i would be interested to
know how we fit them in with the
counties
work on exactly the same stuff
particularly when they come in and do
the flood works
mr careful does the left-hand county
know what the right-hand district is
doing
i'd say yes it does i
say can i defer to mr harris in his
expertise as uh
leading on the flood risk assessments
although obviously the county of the
flood risk authority yes sir again mr
harris
well certainly the the lead local flood
authority the county council have been
involved in the production of the work
done by consultants our consultants have
been touched in touch with them
the local flood authority have advised
our consultants so in this respect yeah
that we have been working very closely
together
that makes me feel a lot better thank
you
cancer junaid
this is an observation from myself
rather than from overview and scrutiny
um
after um the 1998 floods i became a
member of the environment agencies
advisory group and i've kept an eye on
flooding particularly in ulster ever
since keeping records of every single
incident of flooding but also incidents
of flooding um you know i'm no longer
involved with the environment agency by
the way
that was for about four or five years
but one of the observations that i got
that maybe um the officers need to be
aware of is that in my experience um
historically flooding has always been
under recorded incidents of flooding how
it's affected towns how it's affected
buildings in towns and villages they
always seem to be underrecorded
uh and that given that the climate
change means that there will be more
flooding events going forward um i i
would um you know just like to be
assured that that is has been taken into
account and we've still got a lot of old
combined stormwater sewage drains as
well which um does contribute to uh
surface water um the victorian of often
victorian piping uh and i just want
would
like to have reassurance that um that
the the work with the environment agency
and the county council is um you know
seamless and that they look looking
uh at nature-based as well as engineered
solutions going forward for all the
sites that are involved here um i think
there's going to be a lot more incidents
of flooding as we go forward and i i i
just don't have confidence that we've
always captured all the flooding events
in the past
thank you council junior um
hoping for seamlessness is
perhaps a very high threshold um
mr harris would you like to comment
well
again i can say that the consultants
have been advised by the lead local
flood authority the environment agency
and seven trent water that's not to say
of course that all those bodies have got
absolutely comprehensive records but
whatever records they have would have
gone to our consultants
um
i'm slightly amused again on flooding
i'm slightly amused by
uh 1.2.6
page 30
that uh north ladbroke road bishop
sichington has been excluded as
that is a significant slope and i've
never in all my life living in bishop
city never seen water lying even after
the most robust flooding events but
that's uh a comment i think my question
is
um
we are becoming increasingly reliant
on suds schemes
to alleviate
uh potential flooding problems
in um
the the various well as described in the
papers
um
suds only work
clearly if they are properly maintained
um and the design of the
the suds actually um
is sufficiently robust
um and i think we've had we got a lovely
sud in my ward
um but the pipe coming out of it is
normally blocked and the point of your
question is
what can we are we comfortable
that sudden schemes are an appropriate
mitigation
uh given as cancer junit has said that
we are going to see more intense storms
going forward because the substance do
not are not robustly built and more
importantly maintained
then
they don't work
so what reassurance do you have thank
you council kettles
mr carefort how are your sons
well
i think there's a slightly different
point for me mr chairman
regarding the point of the paper it's a
valid point
and yeah moving forward is how how do we
ensure that the
the the engineering solutions that being
provided on site are fit for purpose
and that's something we need to
work with our partners and you know
whether it's the county council the
environment agency to make sure that is
the case and that there are appropriate
uh management
arrangements uh throughout the life of
that development to make sure that they
they function as they should do
what i'll do i'll speak to colleagues in
development management and building
control about that point and come back
to council kettle offline if i may but
so just to point the you know this is
about
quite a high level work looking at the
sites and what this report does conclude
is that a number of more detailed
flood risk assessments are required um
to before sites can come forward but i
think that the general principle that
suds and other on-site flooding
mitigation that does seem to be the way
forward really you deal with the issue
on site to solve it or to prevent it
causing more more problems further
downstream uh but the purpose of this
report say this is a high level uh
assessment and in many cases further
detail work
or determine what yeah whether it's
studs or swales or so forth
which are needed will come forward in
due course
thank you mr carefort i think the
council generally is
recognizes the the imp potential impact
of flooding in the area and that's one
of the reasons why sil money in the past
year or so has been distributed in the
way it has for alleviating uh flood risk
um
you'll note mr careful that counselor
kettle is on your case in this
particular regard and i'm sure you'll
act accordingly um if there's no oh
cancer um shenzhen thank you
it's a good job you're wearing glasses
otherwise i would confuse you
thank you chair
i'm not quite sure i can follow that now
um
it's more
plain devil's advocate here when we look
at the heritage impact assessment
and i'm looking at initially at page 34
at
1.3.24
we talk about here about the high bar
principle if you like
and uh
it shouldn't be an absolute that should
that the fact that it's these are in the
um
[Music]
i'm just looking for the statement high
end of less than substantial
harm uh
shouldn't be an absolute constraint to
development so
we see at 1.3.20
those are included
but then we go back a page to 1.3.13 and
all of those are excluded and i just
wonder could the hive uh why could the
high bar principle be applied to those
or
is there some reason some reason that
i'm i'm not aware of and excuse me for
my ignorance and purpose on this as to
why they are the high bar principle
isn't actually applied to those as well
mr careful can you enlighten our
darkness please
maybe my colleague mr neil may be able
to
do that chairman
thank you
good afternoon everybody i hope you can
all hear me
um the high bar principle in terms of
the high level of lesser substantial
harm has been applied to all the sites
so
there's a consistency of approach
throughout the entire process both
with the consultants and the work we did
in house beforehand
so all the sites that have been listed
in the report would have been assessed
against the same criteria and those
listed have
um ended up being on the list because of
that high bar
being the fact that we feel that
mitigation is less
likely to be successful in mitigating
any substantial harm or high level of
listeners just doubt your heart to those
sites so that's why they've been listed
as being particularly um
brought out in this report as opposed to
others
thank you very much did you
are you comfortable with that answer
cancer shenton
thanks chair thank you
can i ask my question um
if i prefer to
page 32 paragraph 1.3.7
there's reference there to a small
number of sites
uh being
reviewed by heritage consultants and
they've reached different conclusions
um to those originally uh found
i i have no concept of what a small
number is in this context
could i be told how many were looked at
and how many were found to be different
i mean this is this is a question of
either the money was well spent
because lots of differences were found
or the money was well spent because lots
of differences weren't found and we can
rely upon the original work
uh mr if i may just
put some chronology to this so we we had
the uh the preferred options
consultation and through that a number
of what i'll start again actually sorry
members we we undertook in-house um
some heritage work
they informed our preferred options uh
consultation we then had the
consultation and a number of site
promoters uh submitted uh their own
heritage assessments to that
um and then following
that consultation we then uh decided to
um
appoint some heritage consultants of our
own which would purcell
to undertake that um i suppose sense
check and validation of not only our
work but uh also the the work that's uh
that's been done by the site promoters
so the
um
the proportion of um
the whole i'm sure mr neil will tell us
the numbers it was really to
uh to ensure that
uh we were on the right path and in the
whole uh the work that purcell have done
has confirmed that actually we were we
were generally there there have been
some changes but so you might wonder if
mr may have the numbers to hand if not
we can certainly uh provide them
to you chairman
thank you very much i'm quite content
that i'd be
informed later on
unless
the numbers are on
yes um the the numbers were the we
originally in house looked at 125 sites
and we asked purcell to assess 34 which
is about approximately 25 of the sites
um out of those 34 um
i think
one
uh site went from
substantial harm down to a low level of
substantial harm the remainder of them
stayed pretty much the same
as our in-house work in the fact that
they were less than substantial but they
moved around slightly within that the
parameters of less substantial harm
between the high medium and low levels
that purcell introduced to help us
come up with an idea of how to
list or
differentiate between the different
levels of harm within that very wide
band that historic england set
thank you very much that's very helpful
to find um one only out of 125 sounds
like somebody was um
justifying their job shall we say well
done to them thank you
uh
are there any other contributions
questions
counselors
yeah the the um i read all the um the
appendices that were online and the
traffic one in particular was extremely
well done and detailed uh but it did
emphasize quite clearly the impact of
traffic on the town centre of
stratford-upon-avon in particular
and um there does seem to be
no indication yet about what
will happen with the southwestern relief
road and as you know it is controversial
in the town uh and has there been any
indication at all of from government of
um what their thinking is on this
mr can you update us on status of
funding and the government and the
county council concerning the
southwest relief road
uh there's there's nothing from
government per se members um
there was an expectation uh
to be some more more announcements uh
this autumn they haven't materialized as
yet
um
i i think frustratingly it's uh we
obviously we have a new sector of state
and it's understanding what what his uh
priorities are
what we are doing though members and we
can take comfort from this is that we
are continuing lays with uh homes
england the county council and the
developer to see how we can uh bring
forward uh long lasting garden village
and that's the the ultimate aim
and
position of this council so we are
working behind the scenes to to do that
um and yeah hopefully we'll be able to
make further progress uh fairly shortly
thank you
all right thank you i'm intending to
make progress now um on that basis
uh item five uh can i take it that we
are happy that these three reports be
received is that agreeable great thank
you very much
moving on
uh prudential indicators i now revert
to my
portfolio
hold a role and introduce this paper
so i thank myself
the council is required by the sifa
prudential code to set prudential
indicators that ensure that its capital
investment plans are affordable prudent
and sustainable
the purpose of this paper however is to
present the out turn position for 2021
in relation to the chosen prudential
indicators
the paper sets out that the council
approved the 2021 budget that made
provision for the authority to borrow up
to five million pounds in relation to
the development of the material
recycling facility through the arms
length company in which it has a stake
in the event that capital budget was not
drawn upon during 2021 and the council
remained free of debt during the year
the consequence of this was that rather
than incurring an interest charge on
money borrowed the council generated a
positive net revenue stream from its
financing costs as indicated in
paragraph 2.1.2
this amounted to 62.3 uh thousand pounds
and included the impact of the funds
from business rate grants received
during the year the consequence of the
agreed borrowing of up to five million
pounds not having been drawn upon is
recorded in the variance of this amount
reported in paragraph
2.3.4
similarly paragraph 2.5.1
records that the capital the council's
capital expenditure during the year was
less than provision had been made
this for a variety of reasons largely
beyond the council's control resulting
in 8.4 million pounds being carried
forward into
2122
unless there are any questions therefore
might ask members of the cabinet to note
the contents
of the report
no questions
noted passed on
item
seven
this paper is presented because it forms
part of the monitoring process for which
members are responsible it fulfills a
requirement under the sip for code of
practice on treasury management
the effect of paragraphs two and three
is to illustrate that all the council's
capital expense last year of 2.3 million
pounds was financed either by capital
receipts or by capital grants or by
revenue contributions
as shown in on table three on page forty
five the council did not borrow any
funds last year
paragraph four shows that at the end of
the financial year the council had funds
under management of 34 million pounds
all of which was managed by aberdeen
asset management
background 5.1 states that it currently
remains the council's financial strategy
that it should not borrow to finance any
element of its capital expenditure the
remainder of sections five and six of
the report review the level of interest
rates over the review period and those
forecast over the next two years the
bought the broad messages from this
information are number one interest
rates have been and are likely to remain
at historically low rates for the next
couple of years
bank rate has been set at 0.1
since march 2020. that said the bank of
england has recently forecast the rate
of inflation as measured by the cpi will
rise
to four percent by the end of q4 in 2021
financial markets currently are
expecting bank rate to rise to 0.2
percent before the end of 20 to
2022
and to 0.4 percent by the end of 2023
secondly
financial markets are influenced by
amongst other factors economic changes
for example the effect on world trade
arising from the continuing trade
conflicts initiated by the american
government and by the impact of covid19
pandemic which caused has caused
significant volatility in asset prices
and hence yields
thirdly in the context of financial
markets where there is such significant
uncertainty therefore the council's
cautious approach to where and how its
funds are held is merited
section 8 of the paper indicates that
aberdeen
aberdeen's performance
generated a gross return of 339 000
pounds set against the budget assumption
of a hundred and fifty thousand pounds
which itself given that this was a
figure which we had under budgeted in
preceding years it was a almost double
the eighty two thousand pounds budgeted
in the preceding year
this was due predominantly to the larger
than anticipated balances received and
managed to during the year as a
consequence as one of the consequences
of the kovit 19 pandemic i ask therefore
that the report reviewing the treasury
management of the council's funds over
the past year be received
question council barca
what are guilts doing at the moment and
therefore what's the relationship do you
know with the public loans borrowing
um
if they've come up again haven't they
if mr buckland is still on the line i'm
sure he got his finger absolutely on the
financial markets
chairman i thought i might defer to my
section 151 officer if if mike snow was
was available i i haven't been keeping
quite so close to the guild markets
myself well we won't tarry there uh
i'll i'll i'll do my own homework and
and drop your line be canceled
oh mr snow
welcome back from your um sergeants
oh thank you yes well uh live mr
brooklyn i'm not totally in touch with
these things at the moment haven't been
off for the last two weeks but uh as
councillor harvey says i i think we'll
you know just uh
circulate a note after the meeting just
to um
inform members in response to the
question there please
uh what excellent bedtime reason that
will prove to be thank you
i am going to introduce item8
um you'll see here the kovid recovery
plan and the revised social inclusion
action plan
please note that i did raise that
several times that we had changed the
acronym that described that so
where you are seeing action please cross
it out there will be action taken but
not said
um the recommend the recommendations um
are
to note the activity we've undertaken
um
in the community recovery plan and it's
almost as well that i refer you to the
glossary uh
which at the back of
my bit of report whatever page that's on
page 71 sorry where you can just see how
many people and how many groups are
working together and that
for me sums up the the work that we've
done and
the benefit that we've had
from kovid to a certain extent
um
that is now
terminated essentially
um and there are five items still
underway in the recovery plan
but they are being worked on and will be
dealt with when we get to what might be
deemed the end of covid i'm looking at
mr cad who's on the screen and i hope
he's going to nod that we are going to
do those five things yes
excellent
um
second recommendation is to note the
revised social inclusion statement
action plan which runs from last year to
um
march uh sort of now sorry until march
2024
um and we've added some additional
actions and withdrawn others we've added
some additional places which i'm sure
councillor harvey will be very very
pleased that ships to north is
now
because of the increased uptake of
universal credit
one of our one of the areas that we are
actually looking at in terms of social
inclusion where we weren't before
um
and then finally at number three to note
the suggested changes to funding
priorities in the finance section
unless anybody's got any questions i
think it's a i think it's a really well
written report and i like the pictures
nick
thank you before i come to council um
harry
is there anything mr caddy's burning to
say to us
um i think that was a very eloquent uh
summary
succinct to the point well done thank
you we try to be that in this department
chancellor parry
thank you chairman um i would just like
to
um offer my thanks to nick and the team
and to the portfolio holder i think this
is an excellent piece of work very much
needed it covered a wide range of
activities
um
and i'm sure other members of cabinet
would in would would wish to join me in
thanking the team for their hard work
and the differences they've made
to our residents thank you
cancer kettle
yes i i was of course support what
council harry had been saying
um
the one question i have uh nick is on
page 80 of the um
report pack which uh is your priority
themes combating rural isolation you've
mentioned
one two three four settlements
um
two of which are
um main rule centers uh quentin is of
course a um
grade one what are they called um in the
course strategy one of the five uh
enlightened heath is it's it's not
but i could say i think the term europe
is its limited service village i was
going to say ruralization you know
is
far more widespread particularly in the
small smaller hamlets
uh and therefore what actions are you
taking place in those
smaller hamlets which where
the numbers may be fewer but the
isolation may be greater
mr cadre would like to comment
yeah i i can comment on that the whole
premise of the
work that we undertake
through the social inclusion statement
and the social inclusion partnership of
which there are
a host of voluntary and community sector
members
is to
alleviate all forms of poverty and one
form of poverty is obviously
sort of a social poverty and then
isolation
that occurs
both
amongst particular geographies but also
amongst particular
groups of people and the groups of
people i might be referring to by that
include people who are caring for others
or have caring responsibilities
so the
document as a whole and its general
thrust
at addressing the needs of
the more vulnerable
with our communities
i think
addresses across a range of themes and
across a range of different geographies
rural social isolation it connects
people with one another through a number
of different um
projects that we're supporting and a
number of different endeavors that that
whole voluntary and community sector are
engaged in so
whilst i agree i very much appreciate
the point that council of heaven was
raising uh around there being
isolation possibly everywhere and and in
fact one of the um using the using the
measures we we used
to determine this originally
it's worth worth you know the old town
in stratford-upon-avon appears as a as a
uh isolated area because there are many
people there who can't get out of their
own homes easily can't get to activities
easily so
we're fully recognizing of the breadth
of the challenge
thank you mr cat is there any other
officer who wishes to comment
an open invitation
no
cancer junior did you want to speak yes
if i might uh both uh from the ovu and
scrutiny committee uh and from myself um
on from the overview and scrutiny
committee they made it clear that they
wanted to give their thanks to uh to the
team for their work on the recovery plan
and they've noted a very positive update
um from the officers concerned
they also noted that with a small team
and with the help of warwick chicago
they generated an income in excess of
120 000
but they did note that it is not a
statutory service and they saw short
reassurance
that as part of the merger there would
be no reduction in this service
and that they would that would there
would be no uh reduction in the service
that would be available to the residents
from this uh team so that was from the
um overview and scrutiny
remarks from myself it must be noted
that i am an act on energy trustee and
that is mentioned in these papers
and i wanted to ask um about
affordable housing
and make sure that
particularly in ulster that some of the
problems we have in ulster are addressed
the overview and scrutiny committee also
requested could the could orbit be
requested to come to the overview and
scrutiny along with the relevant
portfolio holder to specifically answer
questions on affordable housing and the
provision
of how affordable housing across the
district versus the need
in particular hot spots uh around the
district
and that was a direct request from the
ovum scrutiny committee
sorry
i was going to answer because i can
answer both of
um those you for the um i know i wanted
to just uh raise the fact that we had uh
found that the money for particularly
for the reach out and help and dealing
with domestic abuse which i think is
really important something i feel
totally passionately about
um
rest assured osc
that
non-statutory services will be protected
as far as is humanly possible by
possibly the most
robust of the members of cabinet i.e me
and it'll take a lot to peel my fingers
off the things that we really need to do
to improve the lives of the people who
live in our communities and the things
that actually make a difference and
quite honestly the things that we do
with the teeny weeny team and not very
much money so
um and i'm looking at two of the
officers who are now completely looking
away from me because i think oh god what
she committed us to now
um
and then when we come to talk about
affordable housing i think looking at
lisa barker
we are going to talk to you about it
soon but not yet
watch this space
thank you council
if if the ovule scrutiny committee chair
could be given some reassurance on uh on
our timetable uh i think she would find
that helpful as soon as i have a
timetable she'll have a timetable
thank you i'm pleased that that's going
to be dealt with on a bilateral basis
because i can't see
the relevance of coming to cabinet
without sort of a question because this
you know chairman of uh overview and
scrutiny and the portfolio holder are
both growing up people they can sort
themselves out and arrange their
meetings accordingly and the willing
willing recruit there um i i should say
my a general comment on the question of
um
the merger and services
and uh discretionary or or
non-discretionary
the as i understand it the whole point
of bringing stratford and warwick
district councils together is to ensure
is to face the financial reality and to
ensure that we are in the best possible
position to maintain services as far as
possible and and where possible to
extend them
nobody joined this council from any
party in order to
sit over reduction in services if at all
possible so i think
as far as we can at this stage i think
you should rest assured that we share
your your sentiments
uh just to say that i'm mainly reporting
the uh conclusion from the ovum scrutiny
committee and reporting it to you
thank you so much and i'm sure you'll
report back to them in suitable terms
on that basis if we've concluded our
discussion uh
can i take it that we will note these
three
recommendations to note
in relation to
council's covet 19 community recovery
plan
uh in relation to its social inclusion
statement action plan
and uh the changes to funding priorities
is that agreed
thank you very much
we move on
um
part c of this meeting uh deals with
issues arising from overusing scrutiny
committee there are none
part d deals with cabinet committees and
any issues arising there are none
part e deals with on-block items
to which i referred at the beginning of
meeting
there is no need for discussion those
items are noted
and part f deals with urgent business
i'm not aware of any
on that basis
i close the meeting at 4 28.